good morning believe nation today's
message is practice over to you Alex
Ferguson the advice I give to any young
kid as anyone could play a game of
football anyone the practice makes you a
real football
you see games in a Sunday pub games oh
well they give a football the real
players of the practice a thing about
and well you take that I've never been a
lunch in Glasgow many many years ago and
Gary Player was a classical golfer and
they asked him a question why do you
keep practicing from the bunker because
he was famous for girls bunker says well
I know I'm going to be the in the bunker
at one time in a game maybe twice in a
game and I've got to put in a hole is
that's why I practice and practice and
practice that's a great example of what
you have to do to be alone well I really
love this message I think it's important
for entrepreneurs because I think people
just give up too soon people give up
before they get good at it
I think whenever you're trying something
new you might have certain expectations
you might have a certain level of taste
right you might know what is good but
your abilities to actually produce suck
because you've never done it before just
like any skill that you want to pick up
you wanna learn snowboarding where I
learn French you want to learn how to
make sushi you want to learn you know
how to market a business
at the start you're gonna suck that's
part of the process and people just
expect to be good out of the gate and
they give up way too soon and I think
you you dramatically over asked me what
you can do in a short amount of time but
but underestimate what you can do with
practice over time consistent practice
and I keep coming back to my youtube
channel as an example so you guys are
watching it because I've done now 3000
videos on the channel and I'm still
getting better right and I still don't
think I'm good enough I still want to be
a better speaker a better youtuber I'm
still practicing
but there's 3,000 videos later you know
some people they get 10 videos in there
like I'm not good enough yet you barely
started you know and so it's developing
the routine developing the habit the
practice to get better every single day
you know if you want to be a great
youtuber then dedicate an hour every day
to getting better in front of the camera
even if you never post some videos just
to get practice I remember when I was
reading with my agent and he had me do
my foundation story I did the same story
I don't remember how many times 20 times
30 times and it was a half an hour video
this wasn't just some 1 minute video was
long and I kept doing it and doing it
and doing it and I never publishes any
of the videos I think I made a push put
one up as a raw video every time I did
it it wasn't just to create that end
result it was for me to get better so
the next time I made a new video on
something totally different I would have
more skills and so every video that I
make even now is great for the channel
it helps it provides value but it's also
me practicing to get better and better
and better and better so whatever you
want to get better at just practice and
don't don't give yourself these false
expectations that you're gonna be good
rout of the game you're gonna suck out
of the gate expect it don't get
discouraged keep practicing and just get
better every single day so the question
today is what are you cracked
leave in the comments below will join
the discussion thank you so much for
watching and have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
I've been stressed